well my friends today is such an
important show that I actually got a
haircut for today's show
um the right wing is now attacking John
fetterman for his stroke and yet they
continue to say absolutely nothing about
Herschel Walker's complete inability to
think or speak or coherently explain his
views on even a single issue making it
very obvious that this isn't really
about John fetterman's condition so
let's back up and kind of reset the
stage in Pennsylvania there's a very
important Senate race the Republican
nominee is television Dr Mehmet Oz the
Democratic nominee is the lieutenant
governor John fetterman John fetterman
uh had a stroke some months ago and as
part of his recovery
he is having auditory processing issues
and as a result we learned recently
during an NBC interview that when he is
interviewed he uses closed captioning
meaning that there is a voice to text
um mechanism which shows him on a screen
what he is being asked to kind of
contextualize that here's a report
explaining it and an interview he gave
using that technology another pivotal
Senate race in Pennsylvania now
considered a toss-up are Dasha Burns
spoke at Democrat John Federman in his
first in-person sit-down interview since
he suffered a stroke and Dasha this was
not a typical candidate interview
no Lester because of his stroke veterans
campaign required closed captioning
technology for this interview to
essentially read our questions as we ask
them and Lester in small talk before the
interview without captioning it wasn't
clear he was understanding our
conversation can voters stress that you
will be able to do this job on day one
yeah of course this is Pennsylvania
Democratic Senate candidate John
fetterman's first in-person sit-down
interview since a stroke sidelined him
from the campaign Trail for months that
auditory processing where I'll hear
someone speaking but sometimes I'll be
able to be precise on what exactly that
they're saying I use captioning his
campaign required that he'd be allowed
to use a transcription program on his
computer during our interview I always
thought I was pretty empathetic uh
emphatic I think I was very excuse me
empathetic uh you know that's an example
of the stroke empathetic all right so
you get the picture now I am not going
to pretend for a second that this is a
non-issue
what we are told by doctors is that this
is not a cognitive issue
of fetterman understanding concepts but
that it is an auditory processing issue
which often takes time to get back to
normal for someone who has suffered a
stroke in other words it's turning the
audio into meaningful messages in his
brain now the right many on the right
are saying he should just withdraw
immediately and in fact as if this is
going to be a fair conversation Fox
Business host Maria Bartiromo had
fetterman's opponent Mehmet Oz on and
she said the following well it's also
very questionable to understand the need
to for this computer to be with him and
how is he going to make decisions about
Pennsylvania and fight for the
Pennsylvanian people if in fact he needs
to have a device
alongside him so I mean is this just all
the time he needs that divisors now by
the way Maria Bartiromo can't even do a
TV show without a teleprompter and an
earpiece where producers can talk to her
so it's it's kind of a weird direction
to go just during an interview I don't
understand
no one knows we've not been actually
exposed to this before it's the first
in-person interview here we are you know
less than a month before the election
and I've been asking John Federman to
answer questions on the campaign Trail
initially he wasn't even on the campaign
Trail for the first couple months but
answer questions from voters answer
questions from reporters while you're
actually campaigning that's what we
normally do in a democracy and the
concern of course is that if you don't
ever leave your home and answer
questions we don't know the answers to
the questions you're asking all right so
this is the this is the approach that
they're going with here the reality is
that while we can be concerned about
fetterman's recovery Oz is so dangerous
and so unqualified and so pathetic that
of course Pennsylvania voters should
still vote for John Federman if indeed
what we are being told by doctors about
fetterman's condition is wrong or his
recovery goes in a different way than
predicted
I'm thinking ahead many steps but he
could resign and hopefully then
Democratic governor Josh Shapiro can
select the replacement until the next
election
Oz has no business even being in this
race and so there is really no choice to
be made here now here's John fetterman's
take on all this will you be releasing
updated information from your doctor on
your health before November 8th
I I would say that if there was anything
or whatever I I absolutely would have
updated that you know other than the
progress that I've made it's it's
evident now I certainly not have would
have been able to sit in front of you uh
back in May or in June you know or or
July because they recovered the kind of
recovery that I need in order to be
absolutely uh whatever getting better
and better and I think the ultimate
kinds of transparency is to be in front
of thousands of people on a stage not
using a teleprompter most often kinds of
politicians use a teleprompter but
nobody wonders if he or she is able to
do the job or anything like that uh and
it's simply about that that's how that's
the kind of campaign that I run on so
listen we can all be honest and
recognize whoop that uh that this is not
the same John fetterman right now from
before the stroke we can also understand
that there's not really a choice here
where oh fetterman had a stroke so we're
going to vote for the completely
clueless unqualified hypocrite Mehmet Oz
that doesn't make any sense either and
the right very uh in a very contrived
way talking about this in the context of
fetterman but yet they don't even
mention that Herschel Walker the
Republican candidate in Georgia cannot
speak cannot think lies endlessly and
you can't tell if he's disoriented or
deliberately lying or what they are
total Hypocrites and if you are going to
raise these questions about fetterman
now where have you been for a year on
Herschel Walker who is an embarrassment
to the mere concept of a candidacy let's
talk a little bit about Herschel Walker
next listen Herschel Walker has been
caught in another lie This Time by his
own mother by his own mother you might
remember that one of Herschel Walker's
kids Christian Walker turned against him
and denounced him early last week
calling him a liar calling him a
hypocrite well now Herschel Walker's mom
is saying that story he told about being
full-blooded Cherokee Native American
that story absolutely isn't true The
Daily Beast reporting Herschel Walker's
full blood Cherokee claim is news to his
mom let's start with the video clip this
is from a couple weeks ago here's what
Herschel Walker had to say about his own
supposed Native American ancestry
[Applause]
I found something out of then I'm gonna
end this I found something out my mom
just told me that my mom uh grandmother
was full blood Cherokee so I'm Native
American I was like oh hello so I'm a
I'm a super mutt I don't know what I am
but this is what was so funny this was
so funny I said uh mom uh White never
said anything to us
yeah so he found out that he's full
blood Native American turns out his mom
has no idea what he's talking about
there's a very a good Daily Beast
article here which let's see if I can
pull up we uh have gotten a very
unfortunate paywall here all of a sudden
and I want to have this uh for us so
that we can see it um his mother
indicating she is not aware of such
family history
um if you check out the article you see
that Walker's mother Christine spoke to
Huffington Post and said she has no idea
if an immediate ancestor was
full-blooded Cherokee she said she grew
up hearing stories about her father's
mother being kin to the tribe clarifying
that her grandmother was believed to be
related to Cherokee people's in some way
but didn't know how doesn't know how far
back the Cherokee Heritage goes and has
no further information herschel's
Herschel Walker says I'm full blood
Cherokee recall that when Elizabeth
Warren had actual stories in her family
about being Native American this is the
treatment that she got because you know
we're talking too soon we got a year and
a half left it's like when I called
Pocahontas Pocahontas I should have
waited
six years because she then went out and
got that test
one thousand twenty fourth and I've
always said I have more Indian blood in
me than she has in her and I have none I
have none
but it's more than she has 1025
[Applause]
.
and this went on for months with
Elizabeth Warren but I brought it up too
soon so I don't talk about it anymore
but if she should be the candidate which
I tend to doubt
but if she should be we'll bring it up
again and I think it'll be very
successful
1024. how about this I was driving her
crazy
so she went out and hired a guy to check
the blood
I'm sure he had a lot of fun doing that
he checked your blood
and found out that many many
minutes ago
there could have been
and he could have been in there okay so
uh that that persisted for months now
Herschel Walker just straight up lying
his own mother says I have no idea what
he's talking about within two weeks and
silence Silence from the very same
Republicans who were saying oh Elizabeth
Warren did something so wrong stolen
privilege and all these stolen benefits
by claiming to be Native American which
by the way wasn't even true
um the double standards you know I don't
really care who's Native American I
don't really care about you know if
there's if there's a cognitive issue or
a health issue whatever fetterman Walker
would just be consistent guys that's all
I'm asking for just please be consistent
let me know your thoughts find me on
Twitter at D Pacman we will take a very
brief break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David pakman show continues to be a
program that depends on the support of
our viewer and listener Community we
have something called the membership
program you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code big voting22 for a discount and you
will get instant access to the Daily
bonus show the commercial free audio and
video streams of the show and exclusive
members only Town Halls where I open the
phone lines and take questions from you
from the members sign up at
joinpakman.com we're continuing to learn
in uh fits and starts and spurts and
bits and pieces I don't know more and
more about the extraordinarily bizarre
times at Mar-A-Lago related to this FBI
search warrant the raid the documents
Etc and the latest from The Washington
Post is that Donald Trump told a worker
move boxes of documents after the
government subpoena was received which
is another indicator if true that Donald
Trump knew exactly what was where and
was specifically involved in trying to
hide documents from authorities key
witness and security camera footage
there's video offer evidence of Trump's
actions after the government subpoena
people familiar say
look at this a trump employee has told
federal agents about moving boxes of
documents at Mar-A-Lago at the specific
direction of the former president
according to people familiar with the
investigation who say the witness
account combined with security camera
footage offers key evidence of Donald
Trump's Behavior as investigators sought
the return of classified material the
witness description and footage
described to The Washington Post offered
the most direct account to date of
Trump's actions and instructions leading
up to the FBI search on August 8th
uh where agents were looking for
evidence of potential crimes the people
familiar with the investigation said
agents said agents have gathered witness
accounts indicating that this is the key
element
after Trump advisors received the
subpoena in May for any classified
documents remaining at Mar-A-Lago Trump
told people move boxes to his residence
at the property
that description of events was
corroborated by security camera footage
there is video which showed people
moving the boxes said the people who
spoke on the condition of anonymity to
discuss an ongoing investigation no
comment from the justice department
um no comment from Trump's spokesman
Taylor budowich other than the Biden
Administration has weaponized law
enforcement and fabricated a document
hoax in a desperate attempt to retain
political power
um folks this is more evidence of
obstruction this is Trump trying to hide
his alleged violations of the Espionage
Act this was immediately called fake
news
and then of course it's oh we have the
footage we have the video footage we
have the surveillance footage showing a
staffer moving boxes out of the storage
room and moving them to another location
so there is really one major story here
and many dozens of you every single day
write to me and say David there's sort
of like tons of evidence that this guy
obviously should be indicted we're not
saying imprisoned we're saying evidence
for an indictment and then go through
the process and determine whether there
is guilt the real story here to me
continues to be the doj Department of
Justice FBI law enforcement federal law
enforcement investigating all of this
they have an almost absurd amount of
evidence at this point in time to
justify an indictment
doesn't guarantee a guilty verdict it
doesn't guarantee necessarily even a
guilty plea but if this were anyone
other than a former president there is
such extensive evidence that there would
have been an indictment already why is
there no indictment is Merrick Garland
not actually willing to indict we had
this investigation in New York which we
covered and if you've been watching the
show May ring a bell in which two of the
investigators resigned and of course
when this happened the trumpists all
came out of the woodwork and they had
the same story ready to go and that
story was oh the investigators resigned
because they realized it's a Witch Hunt
and there's no evidence
that was wrong the resignations were
actually quite the opposite the
investigators resigned because despite
all of the evidence they were finding
they believed that there was not
actually a willingness from higher-ups
to indict Trump they felt the
investigators felt as though their work
was completely in vain that they were
doing the work they were finding the
evidence and yet they would bring it
bring it bring it to their bosses
and they sensed a total lack of
willingness from their bosses to
actually go through with an indictment
they said what the hell are we doing
here they're we're working in vain we're
working for nothing and they resigned at
this point in time and we will see as
we're recording Today's Show the January
6 committee uh hearing is uh taking
place scheduled to start momentarily you
will probably know more about it than I
know now by the time today's episode
goes live
the amount of evidence is really piling
up here
are we going to get an indictment and
remember I'm actually for Law and Order
so when I say are we going to get an
indictment I don't go to lock anybody up
I don't go to Railroad anyone with
charges what I go to is there seems to
be enough evidence for an indictment
that's the step I'm talking about the
right on the other hand claims to be for
Law and Order and yet they say lock up
Hillary
lock up Joe Biden lock up Hunter Biden
uh lock up antifa lockup BLM lock up
people who haven't even been charged and
in many cases who aren't even under
investigation that's not Law and Order
Law and Order is look at all this
evidence against Trump it's time to
indict that's where we are another
interesting story a legal Story related
to the failed former president that I
briefly want to talk about
um a judge has ruled that Donald Trump
indeed must give evidence in this
um a defamation lawsuit related to
alleged rape by Donald Trump the hill
reports a federal judge has denied
former president Trump's motion to pause
the proceedings of a defamation suit
against him from a woman who has accused
him of rape while appeals over the case
play out setting him up for a deposition
next week this is I know Trump was
recently deposed by Leticia James
this is another deposition in another
case now as a reminder this is not a
criminal rape case this is a lawsuit for
defamation related to the things Donald
Trump said about a rape accuser
e Gene Carroll U.S District Judge writes
the hill Lewis Kaplan ruled yesterday
that Trump's argument didn't meet the
legal threshold required for a stay to
be issued Trump has been pushing for the
U.S to be substituted in E Gene
Carroll's lawsuit against him because
the comments Trump made denying her
claim and criticizing her happened when
he was president Trump's argument is I
shouldn't be the defendant in this
lawsuit for the things I said about
Eugene Carroll including if I recall
correctly that she's not really his type
as if that's a reason rather than saying
I don't rape people he said she's not my
type
doesn't make sense that I would have
raped her insane
he says he was president at the time and
thus really the federal government
should be the defendant rather than him
um the hill notes the details of the the
case here Carol accused Trump of raping
her at a Manhattan department store in
the 90s Trump has countered by accusing
Carol of lying and making remarks
criticizing her appearance yeah
Trump requested that proceedings in the
defamation case that Carol filed be
paused while the D.C court of appeals
weighs whether Trump was acting in His
official capacity when I said she was
too ugly to rape I was functioning in an
official capacity so the federal
government should be the defendant
that's where we are in 2022 at this
point in time Kaplan wrote in his ruling
the court could rule either way on the
question but Trump gave no reason for
him to conclude that the ruling would be
in his favor he also found that Trump
failed to show a meaningful meaningful
threat of irreparable injury if a stay
is not put in place
uh listen you can't sue me for
defamation because I was acting in my
official capacity as president at that
time now what do we expect he will do
if indeed he is deposed probably plead
the Fifth at his last deposition with
Leticia James Trump pled the fifth about
400 times Trump previously has said only
the mob pleads the fifth you don't plead
the fifth if you're innocent his own
experience with the deposition changed
his mind on that surprisingly the
important thing to remember is that as a
defendant in a civil suit pleading the
fifth may not be as useful to him as it
can be in a criminal case I heard from a
criminal defense attorney who said you
know
in this is a criminal defense attorney
who wrote to me and said David Sir With
Tears in his eyes he said David sir when
I defend people criminally
juries are given instructions that the
lack of testimony from my client or
pleading the fifth cannot be used to
draw negative inferences or to point
towards guilt you can't hold against
them that they don't testify or that
they pled the fifth in a civil lawsuit
Trump or whoever pleading the fifth or
refusing to answer questions can be used
to draw a negative inference and
theoretically as part of a guilty
verdict we're thinking many steps ahead
but an important difference in terms of
civil versus criminal now I know many of
you are wondering what about the
criminal aspect of this
um
to be honest I don't know where that
stands I know that there are questions
as the statute of limitations this
alleged event happened during the 90s
and a number of other obstacles but what
we're dealing with right now is a civil
suit for defamation wherein I'm sort of
breaking this down to its its kernel of
Truth
Trump sort of said e Gene Carroll is not
attractive enough for me to actually
have raped she's not my type which is a
crazy thing to say uh we'll have more on
this and Other Stories from today on our
Instagram you can find that at
davidpackman show and we will be right
back after this short break
if you value what we do at the David
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show it's great
to have back on the program today
Douglas rushkoff who's a media theorist
professor at Cooney Queens College and
also author of the new book survival of
the richest Escape fantasies of the tech
billionaires which I recently read and
very much enjoyed really great having
you on today I appreciate it it's good
to see you so the kind of jumping off
point of the book is that you are
invited by some billionaires uh to meet
with them and the meetings sort of goes
a little bit differently maybe they than
you anticipated where they want advice
not so much about the technology of how
to survive a possible impending Mass
catastrophic event but more sort of like
socio-cultural and psychological
questions about like how do I prevent my
security force from turning against me
and sort of like taking all my food and
kind of this type of thing and one of
the big points you make in the book
which I find interesting is that these
billionaires are now looking to sort of
insulate themselves from the
consequences of the very system that
they used to enrich themselves in the
first place talk first just kind of
generally about this space that exists
this um uh sort of catastrophe and
disaster planning space and is it only
billionaires or is it also like the
hundred millionaires that are into this
it gives us a sense of the lay of the
land well it's interesting I mean
these guys in some ways these guys give
a bad name to Preppers everywhere you
know I I met a lot of Preppers since
doing this book and real preppers are
generally involved in strengthening
their communities they understand that
when you have Community resilience when
you've got local farms when you've
supported that you're gonna everyone's
gonna do better and these guys are not
are not Preppers in that sense they've
got such a go It Alone you know
self-sovereign individual you know
extreme libertarian understanding of
technology and money and identity that
they um wither without catastrophe they
want a private island they want a little
c-steading raft of their own they want
their own country their own government
you know their own social network their
own virtual womb you know that could
that can care for them so Audrey and
enough I started to look at their
disaster prep and catastrophe mindset
more as a way of justifying what they've
been doing all along you know there's
there's I just read a piece by Corey
doctorow about Epson printers and how
Epson makes a printer that bricks itself
after it prints out a certain number of
pages it just breaks itself and there's
no really good reason for it but except
that they want to sell Another Printer
you know and they justify it that oh
well the parts are going to be worn out
by then so we we spare the user the
hassle of of having a broken printer and
we just lock it you know but there's a
guy right there's and I'm assuming it's
a guy there's a guy at Epson printer
somewhere thinking well yes this means
I'm going to have to send more kids into
the mines in Africa to get their rare
earth metals to make another printer and
yes we're gonna have to take that
existing printer and just Chuck it onto
a landfill where it's going to Leach
toxic chemicals and yes I am actually
shortening the amount of time between
now and whatever catastrophic climate
event takes down our civilization but
the margin I'm making selling these
extra printers must be making me enough
money so I can get my kid to a Rudolph
Steiner school and get a goat share and
live in a private Farm somewhere and be
insulated from this that I can stay that
much ahead and that's really what it's
always been these guys with an exit
strategy mentality needing to stay just
one or two steps ahead of the rest of
the investors so they can get out with
their carpet bag before the thing comes
down yeah and in the book you you refer
to the mindset which I think
incorporates some some of these ideas
that you're talking about here you know
one of the things that I I've read is
you know the prep the sort of like
normal Preppers and then the the
billionaires you're talking about here
and then like everybody else whatever
some of the advice I've read kind of is
summarized as follows which is listen it
makes sense to plan for like a 10 to 14
day
cataclysm of some kind food water maybe
electricity with a generator you know
that that makes sense beyond that
it is so truly difficult to really set
yourself up to survive what we might
call long term in such an event that
it's not even really worth thinking
about that is increasingly something I'm
reading from a lot of these things but
when you say that though the implication
of that and that's what I the
implication of that is that means that
becoming a billionaire even without the
catastrophe is not the way to make
yourself the most safe and resilient
overall exactly exactly and so I guess
when is it that the billionaires think
that doesn't apply to them because of
the amount of money that they have
it's that the billionaires are aware
that they've spent the last 10 or 20
years of their lives
externalizing so much harm to the rest
of the world that they are afraid of it
coming back at them like Karma you know
most of these guys they are unconscious
Tech bro billionaires for the first 10
or 20 years and then they go down to
Burning Man and do some Ayahuasca and
realize oh my God the planet is crying
out to me she's dying you know they have
the same realization but then on the G5
back to San Jose they're like okay now
how do I protect myself from her like
the angry girlfriend that you haven't
called in a long time the planet you
know is coming for Revenge so the
question that I found really interesting
from the book which I already mentioned
is this idea of I I can do everything
right as a billionaire with every
resource available to me but if we
really get to a cataclysm my security
team might just turn against me and be
like let's kill this one guy and we can
keep all the food and we can survive you
talk in the book about well the way to
preempt that is probably to for the
years leading up to this event build uh
relationships and and cooperate and you
know make it so that they would see you
as one of them so to speak and not not
try to do that is that really are they
satisfied with that advice no because
they understand what that advice is is
really a trojan horse to try to break
down their mentality right I said to
them at that at that talk I said well
the way to make sure your head is
security doesn't kill you in the bunker
is pay for his daughter's Bat Mitzvah
today right you know and I meant that in
some ways as a as a little Jewish joke
um but
they would have to do more than pay for
that one guy's daughter's Bat Mitzvah
and while you're at it think about your
workers and while you're at that think
about the people living in the community
around you think about the the if you're
a Facebook executive think about the
tent Village right outside corporate
headquarters who are those people right
how do you look at them not as a city
problem but as a human problem you know
not something to bulldoze out of there
but something to actually address and
look at the actual impact of your
company on the world so if they started
thinking that way then there might not
be a catastrophe for them to hide from
at all right but they're attached to it
and that's partly I mean that's really
what the book looks at is how to
capitalism and the history of technology
and science and this kind of Dominator
mindset how do they all combine to
create this kind of colonial Vision
where all they can do is operate one
level above the rest of us you know they
kind of go from zero to one as T Peter
teal would say or go meta as Zuckerberg
would say right do derivatives of
derivatives as a finance guy would say
it's always one level up that's what
what Stuart brand said back in the the
70s you know we are as gods and we may
as well get good at it and the tech Bros
have taken that as as kind of a gospel
truth is your sense that these folks
you've talked to are more convinced that
such a world-changing event is coming
than other groups or is it simply that
they are more focused on using their
resources to prepare themselves for it
they're more convinced actually and
that's you know it's funny after I I
wrote the first article on this book
I've gotten calls from lots and lots of
people in interesting places and one of
them is a giant hedge fund which is a um
uh a hedge fund that's positioned for
Global Calamity you know it's got a few
billion dollars in there and they showed
me their PowerPoint with charts from the
World Bank and the climatologists of
this and like okay in the next 10 years
these regions will become unlivable ten
years after that these ones will be the
only ones that have fertile soil this is
why we recommend buying land in Northern
Canada Siberia Greenland and this part
of Antarctica and it's like oh my God
and so
if they're being pitched those kinds of
things that we are not pitched and
they're so realistic
um and I suppose probable right because
people with real money do real studies
then then I think they are sort of more
aware of it than we are and I think they
understand that they're more causal to
it than we are we're just eating our
food and throwing out some plastic bags
occasionally and feeling guilty that we
know the recycling actually uses more
energy than it would cost to make a new
plastic bottle or whatever you know
where but these guys it's like Oh no
you're doing major you're doing things
at scale you know and you're doing
things at scale with a business model
that looks at all the damage as an
externality to your business and you're
aware that those externalities are
growing big enough to impact your life
and the lives of your kids
in the book you talk about technology
that some see maybe naively as maybe a
way out of some of the problems that
we've created for ourselves
um you talk a little bit about solar
panels and electric vehicles I think and
now I'm not sure if I'm if I'm if this
is from the book or from articles you've
written but in any case you've expressed
that you are less optimistic about some
of these Technologies uh being able to
kind of meet our energy needs in a truly
eco-friendly way I think there's a lot
of legitimacy to that the carbon
footprint of solar panels which degrade
over time and then what do we do with
them Rare Earth minerals required for
electric vehicle batteries what do you
do with the battery has reached the end
of its usable life Etc
just maybe I'm naive but isn't there
some degree to which those are problems
that can be significantly improved upon
by by engineering and the technology
simply improving from where it is today
that will change the scale and actually
make those Technologies genuinely game
changers maybe not the solution but
significantly significant improvements
oh
moving away from fossil fuels and
combustion is a necessary part
of the planet
Ary civilization moving toward
sustainability okay
saying over the next 10 years we're
going to convert every car to an
electric car and every house to a solar
panel house in order to get to zero
carbon emissions by 2030
is crazy because the amount of stuff
that we would dig up yeah in order to do
that energy with the amount of the
factories we'd have to open to build all
those cars and do all that stuff and
build all those batteries would destroy
us faster than anything else
so
that's my volunteer fire alarm the
volunteer fire department in our town is
old Tech that's what we're hearing now
they they extend that alarm and then
they check their pages to see
um where's the fire and they go it's
Community right right gotta love it you
gotta love it
um and they're volunteers
um it's gonna go one more time they do
it twice like if people woke up and
didn't hear how many beeps it was to
know if they're active but um
the these are all great but the amount
of energy we're using now is
you know a great uh energy theorist
named uh Nate Nate hoggins talks about
this it's like a pulse of energy we're
not using energy in like a
we're using like explosions of energy in
order to power these cities the the the
you know hundreds of thousands of years
of stored energy that gets burnt in like
two days is is you know a massive and
unsustainable so uh we we also need to
reduce the amount of energy we use you
know and that's not
shockingly hard you know we built the
American landscape around the needs of
the automobile industry where people
have to drive to get to work and all so
there are many many ways to reduce our
energy footprint that of our of our
corporations and that of our us as
individuals and it it involves a lot of
economic rejiggering too if you've got
an oil industry that's depending on
resource depletion and you've got all
these pensioners who are dependent on
the oil industry or an S P 500 or a GDP
that's depending on the growth of
companies that are destroying us you
kind of do have to do more than the
physical re-engineering of energy
production but the the code engineering
of our economy you know and that's where
it gets scary Yeah you mentioned GDP so
I again I don't remember exactly where
you wrote this but I've read something
you wrote about you know uh criticism of
401ks and uh the sort of stock market as
a pyramid scheme I think was the analogy
that that you used I'm there's this
interview I remember at some point Noam
Chomsky gave where he was sort of like
confronted and I used that in in scare
quotes he was confronted about the fact
that despite all of his criticisms of
all these different types of companies
um his like retirement accounts are
invested in the same you know kind of
index funds that that everybody uses and
his response was something like well
yeah I mean what you want me to keep the
money under my mattress or some
something along those lines are you
despite your view on the impossibility
of indefinite growth based on GDP growth
on a planet with limited resources your
criticism of 401k Etc are you invested
in the same stuff
some yeah I mean that was the main thing
I'm in a group called Equitable
Enterprise at Institute for the future
in in uh they're like in Palo Alto and
they were talking about all these new
models and all this and that's what I
brought up in the first meeting I said
what if we all took 50 of our retirement
savings and invested them locally or in
land trusts or in other things and
people are like
well I won't really we've got to make
structural change that one and I think
yeah I know you got to make structural
change and all that but what if we by
example did it and then encouraged
everybody else to take just half of
their retirement savings let's say we
could only they kept saying it was just
such a small measure saying what if we
could only move a couple of trillion
dollars into local economics you know
what would that do it would be massive a
massive amount of change so yeah one of
the main things I'm looking at is how do
we and I hate using words like scale but
how do we make it really easy for people
instead of selecting s p Index Fund to
select local index billion small
businesses fund how do we invest in land
trusts you know you're going to get
different kinds of returns you're going
to end up getting dividend returns and
earnings returns rather than the capital
gains of selling some massively thing
you're not going to get 100 x Returns on
restoring local businesses at least not
for that long you know you might hit
beginning as we recover a local economy
but you know that's what I'm looking at
so I'm looking at lots of um I mean I'm
invested in land trusts and uh there's
some local farming uh things you know
funds where you you you lend money to
Farmers at a low interest rate and get
it back so you know I'm I'm looking at
you know three and four percent returns
as a good thing rather than a bad thing
you know and
just because I earned money doesn't mean
I'm allowed to have my money be worth
more later you know that doesn't I can
I'll save up money for my retirement but
I also then you know in addition to
wanting to get to you know just hold my
money certainly at the rate of inflation
um I want to create a community that
will support me when I'm older so I'm
not entirely dependent on my cash right
to take care of me when I'm old and that
means engendering a different kind of
society and you walk around Europe you
see old people they're living in the
house with their kids they're they're
part of the social fabric they're out
there on the stoop at night playing with
the babies and taking care of the little
ones so the husband and wife can go down
to the movies and the teenagers can make
out over there and these guys it's like
a a an interdependent Society you know
and that's what a social economy is
that's what Marx was talking about not
some big top-down central government
organization he was like no no economics
is social it's people doing things for
one another and maybe it's not on The
Ledger maybe there's not a doubt or a
blockchain keeping track of whether
Grandma took care of the kids for two
hours so now someone's going to give her
a bath you know you don't need to put
that on the blockchain
last thing just because you mentioned it
is the entire crypto thing over
no the entire crypto thing is not over
it
it may have gone through
it may have gone through the.com bust
the equivalent of 1999 2000 and then
we'll see you know there was there were
two possibilities after the.com bust we
kind of got blogger and Friendster and
Napster and some interesting things but
then we also got Myspace and Facebook
and Instagram and the ucky ones won
right rather than the kind of pro-social
creative ones I'll be interested to see
if the the young crypto community that
I'm still aware of the the kids who are
making nfts for good reasons not to
become millionaires but to support their
art and the kids who are building Dows
you know Dows that help other people
make Dows in order to figure out the
governance structure of their
organization or their Community if those
people went out then um crypto could
come back in a positive way if crypto
comes back as you know what it was
before which is a way for [ __ ] to
speculate on you know abstract assets
then you know All Is Lost the latest
book is uh survival of the richest
Escape fantasies of the tech
billionaires we've been speaking with
the book's author media theorist and
Professor Douglas rushkoff always great
having you on really appreciate it oh I
appreciate what you do
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right a truly Blockbuster media
story Infowars conspiracy theorist Alex
Jones has been ordered to pay nearly a
billion dollars in his latest trial
flipped out started requesting money
from his audience we are going to look
at the verdicts and this is just
unbelievable the Associated Press
article on the screen lays out the
specifics Alex Jones ordered to pay
965 million dollars for his Sandy Hook
lies jurors ordered Jones to pay nearly
a billion dollars to Sandy Hook
Elementary School shooting victims
relatives and an FBI agent who said he
turned their loss and Trauma into years
of Torment by promoting the lie that the
Rampage was a hoax this is the second
big judgment against Jones for spreading
the myth that the deadliest school
shooting in history never happened the
verdict came in a defamation suit filed
by some of the families of 26 people
killed in that 2012 shooting
plus an FBI agent among the First
Responders you may recall we covered it
and spoke to lawyer Mark Bankston a
Texas jury in August awarded nearly 50
million dollars to the parents of
another slain child Robbie Parker
remember Robbie Parker lost his
six-year-old daughter Emily he's one of
the people that Alex Jones suggested was
a so-called crisis actor here is an
incredible moment the verdicts being
read in the courtroom
ladies and gentlemen of the jury please
listen to your verdict as it is right
okay
verdict be the jury has reached our
verdict as to damage it in this case we
wore damages to each plaintiff and
against Adam stones and Free Speech
Systems LLC as follows
Roman number one compensatory damages
instructions filling both numbers for
each plaintiff then go to section two
please enter your damage damages
assessments for each plaintiff on the
lines below
two plaintiff Robbie Parker a defamation
slash slander damages past the future 60
million dollars
be emotional distress damages past and
future 60 million dollars wow total fair
just and reasonable damages to Plaintiff
Robert Parker and against Alex Jones and
Free Speech systems and line a and line
B total 120 million dollars the initial
by juror number one
two plaintiff David wheeler a defamation
slash slander damages fast and future 25
million dollars
the emotional distress damages past and
future with 30 million dollars total
Fair adjust and reasonable damages to
Plaintiff David wheeler and against Alex
Jones and Free Speech systems at line a
and line B 55 million dollars
these verdicts continued and continued
and continued in different plaintiffs
being awarded varying amounts of money
remember what attorney Mark Bankston
told us when I interviewed him a few
weeks ago that these subsequent cases
would end Infowars they would end
Infowars now Alex Jones says that that's
not going to happen and he immediately
immediately took to the airwaves and uh
started
um asking for money essentially take a
listen to this they want to scare
everybody away from freedom and scare us
away from questioning Uvaldi and what
really happened there or Parkland or any
other event and guess what we're not
scared and we're not going away and
we're not going to stop
and literally for hundreds of thousands
of dollars I can keep them in court for
years I can appeal this stuff we can
stand up against this travesty against
the billions of dollars they want it's a
joke so please go to infowarstore.com
and get Vitamineral Fusion get X3 right
give the solution to this travesty is
getting Vitamineral Fusion
all the great products
better there that keep us on air at
infowarstore.com yeah okay so I don't
know whether this will end Infowars you
know one of the questions I had for
plaintiff's attorney Mark Bankston who
who was involved in the Texas case was
what about collecting the money okay you
got it you got a judgment you got a
verdict
how do you collect the money
he said without going into detail that
as attorneys they have ways of doing
that and that they will collect uh the
vast majority of this money now does
Alex Jones have a billion dollars not
from everything I knew
but is the whole point that the verdict
exceeds his actual assets by so much
that it will completely end Infowars now
to be clear I think it's important to
say it's not about taking pleasure
in the financial demise of Jones or
Infowars necessarily it's more that
there has to be some responsibility for
people who have public platforms and I
include myself in this there has to be
some responsibility and accountability
and the
financial and legal problems should
correlate with the degree to which your
actions are deplorable wrong dishonest
and unethical Jones actions over the
last many years be going Beyond even the
Sandy Hook uh Fiasco have been the
lowest of the low and so it is just that
the financial and legal consequences are
uh commensurate with that
that's the point not about cheerleading
someone's Financial ruin we will follow
it we will see what can be collected and
there are more cases coming folks this
is not the end of it
right-wingers have gotten us banned from
being able to post a tick tock
I don't even know where to start but
this is quite frankly completely
demoralizing we have been posting on the
platform Tick Tock for a while now we
have built up more than 200 000
followers on Tick Tock the fastest
growth of any platform on which we have
ever published content has been Tick
Tock the growth has been incredible it
has become a huge part of our content
distribution
tick tock's content moderation system is
a disaster it's heavily automated
and it appears as though when human
reviewers are involved they either don't
understand the content or are hypocrites
I don't know and because we have had
dozens of videos flagged by right
Wingers wrongly flagged as violating all
sorts of different disinformation
policies although most of those we have
appealed successfully
enough of them we have not that now we
are banned from posting to tick tock for
some period of time take a look at this
when we enter Tick Tock we now see your
account is in view only mode that means
can't post can't comment due to multiple
violations of our community guidelines
your account is restricted to view only
mode the next violation could result in
being permanently banned
this is a major hit
to what we are doing and the messages we
are trying to get out look at some of
these examples of our violations Senator
Mike Braun says he would be okay leaving
the legality of interracial marriage to
states that was from March we posted
that and said how horrible it was that
Mike Braun said that Mike Braun really
said that we got a violation
because the content was found to be uh
intended to deceive or mislead
that's insane we were debunking what
Mike Braun genuinely said next example I
interviewed Bobby pyton a republican for
U.S Senate he made false claims about
the 2020 election I debunked those
claims
and we got a violation for them
Trump is confused by election fraud
documentary this was an interview that
Luke Beasley did with someone who told
lies about the 2020 election Luke
Beasley confronted those lies lies we
called out those lies
and it was found to violate Community
guidelines and we also have one which is
under appeal
wherein Donald Trump called Joe Biden
the Enemy of the State that's literally
what Trump said we talked about how
corrosive and destructive that is we
received
a community guideline strike these are
right Wingers Mass reporting us so what
can we do I don't know
if you work at Tick Tock if you know
anyone who works at Tick Tock please get
us in touch email info davidpackman.com
this is a really important platform on
which we are reaching young people who
vote
this is a huge part of our Outreach and
the Maga people by mass reporting us
have gotten it taken away and part
listen they do this on every platform
they do this on YouTube YouTube has
figured out
how not to allow these people it's just
simply because they don't like my
opinion to shut down my channel Tick
Tock has not figured it out
if you know anyone at Tick Tock please
get in touch put us in touch we need
help
in addition
get yourself some membership on our
website we all all of these platforms
take up time and resources and every
time that something like this happens we
then have to request additional help and
additional resources and additional time
the best thing we can do in order to not
rely on any individual platform is to
continue growing the direct support from
our viewers so I would love it if you
signed up at joinpakman.com coupon code
big voting 22 gets you a discount all
right I posted this to my Twitter
yesterday and so many people were
insanely triggered by it as many of you
heard former democratic congresswoman
Tulsi gabbard announced that she was
leaving the Democratic party earlier
this week not a surprise she's been a
right-wing reactionary for a long time
she also started a podcast
I came across it it looks like she just
copied our logo I mean straight up it
just looks like she copied our logo we
have both logos up on the screen right
now
um the David Pacman show the Tulsi
gabbard show the concept is exactly the
same as our logo it is a sort of square
logo slightly rectangular with the and
show in perfectly vertical
non-italicized text and then much like
in our logo where David Pacman is
slightly italicized and at an angle it's
the exact same with Tulsi gather now I
posted this to my Twitter
70 seriously thirty percent ingest I
mean it's clearly our logo I'm not
claiming to have a copyright on on
slanted italicized text the tool see
stands or tool sells or whatever you
want to call them
they went nuts coming out of the
woodwork saying David you're a shill you
don't own copyright on italics you're a
disgusting person
these folks are so triggered guys it's
sort of a joke but also it does seem
like someone copied our logo relax okay
we're just having a good time and by the
way the podcast the Tulsi gabbard
podcast it sounds like Ben Shapiro I
mean the idea that she was genuinely a
Democrat it's a pathetic joke we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
David P
this may be my favorite story about one
of our newest viewers an 81 year old
Canadian grandmother listened to this
David
um long time listener uh so I just
wanted to tell you a funny story my 81
year old grandmother who found you on
Facebook I recently found out that she
watches you every day so
um you can put that in the bank up here
in Canada I love that
um additionally I just wanted to mention
that I really appreciate your slight
comical
nuances that you have on the show I
really appreciate that because life and
the politics can get so serious very
quickly so I appreciate having a laugh
every day
um when I watch your show well I really
appreciate that and say hello to Grandma
for me I absolutely love that we have a
great bonus show for you today the stop
the steal people
are training so-called poll observers to
wreak complete havoc in November at
polls around the country
Dennis Prager says that there is no
secular argument against incest were it
not for religion everybody would be I
guess having sex with their sister
sounds weird
um and then Tulsi gabbard is immediately
jumping into campaigning for a
republican she's now an independent she
left the Democratic party but she's not
a right-wing nut but she's immediately
campaigning for a republican okay all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show don't miss it sign up at
joinpakman.com
thank you